hi I'm David Hornsby I'm Ashley Burch
I'm Daniel pudy and we're here to talk
about our first time
director yes directly I'm sorry
directing
[Music]
I definitely had moments where I was
like why do I want to cut everything
that I'm in down to as minimal as
possible and I was like oh it's just
because I'm an actor it's not that hard
right it's not that hard you just do
your thing and then you're like all
right we good okay let's move on I
didn't even yell action or cut I don't
think I did one one time yeah that's
true act like it's more involved yeah
maybe yeah guys this is very difficult
yeah I'll tell the camera the camera
people here you guys don't you know how
hard it is Mr brittlesby is very busy if
you're mentally ill I'd be more than
happy to drive you to a nearby Asylum
Joe please what did Rob and Megan say to
you in terms of advice for directing
nothing
uh don't screw it up no I don't know
they were just like you'll be fine yeah
Rob said come with a plan be prepared to
throw it out if your gut is Right 51 of
the time
that's a good gut Megan said babysit be
a good babysitter who is she talking
about
but it was good I feel like I learned a
lot it was a nice way to like really
appreciate and see the you know how much
goes into into the show about you didn't
say anything
they said uh we're leaving if you got
this then we're gonna go home I was like
yeah that's fine that's fair that's fair
go how do I look big time Hollywood
producer more like big time Hollywood
pedophile what are you the most proud of
for me episode that it's complete I hope
that my episode is done I'm so proud of
that I think I'm gonna Echo that with
just getting it covered I think that
there was a few scenes where I was like
I just hope we covered it all you know
like you were in a great scene with Rob
where you were both improving a lot
about you know Superman and flying and
shoe size and would you like to know the
size 13. let me see that let me see that
oh that is so sad I was like I hope we
got it all you know and I think we did
and uh that's all nice when I went and
saw with with Josh the editor and being
like okay it cuts together I think I'm
the most proud that during my episode
The Crew wasn't like
yeah all right yeah actor directing cool
cool cool yeah did anything surprise you
when you were like doing it I was
surprised that I wasn't a total mess
honestly you were a really great yeah
you faked it very well
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a writer Brad ugh
yeah how did you find giving actors
notes what's the uh what's a nice way to
say you want something different
ask a question I realized while I was
directing that
I have to use less words
not to just blow smoke
I never was in the position where I was
like oh that just didn't work it was
more like oh it would be fun to try this
free money for example she had a scene
with Rob and Charlotte and to have a a
moment of going up to her and being like
you don't like poppy so just play it
like that like everything you say to her
you don't like her you like iron you
don't like her and then it was just cool
to see what came out Dana Dana Dana Dana
what hey um you just backed me up I find
it's best to um like if you approach an
actor you kind of you come low oh my God
right you get low and you have a treat
with you right and you and you say hey
I'm gonna
you want you want a little and then you
can say whatever you want but you give
them the treat and you get your hand
away fast because they will bite it
um and then and then you walk away and
and then you know they'll usually do it
I think I was that was I found the best
process do you guys find that to be the
case
great meeting
oh so
so check out our next season of Mythic
Quest and see if you can guess who
directed what episode without looking at
the credits first yes
[Music]
being a director on a TV show you want
to get everything that you need to get
but also not be someone that is keeping
everyone needlessly long and you know
whatever like now
[Laughter]